Friends, among all the health threats that
exist in the world today, right now it’s
a virus that stands head and shoulders above
all others.
There is virtually no headline or programme
that doesn't address the news.
It's the news event of the year.
And the truth is, that to this day, it is
not about the number of people infected or
the apparent lethality that worries us, it
is above all else the newness of the threat
and the fact that we still do not know exactly
what we are facing that makes it so terrifying.
There are no vaccines and beyond the treatment
of symptoms, there isn’t a specific cure.
I'm sure you don't need any more clues at
this point to know what we're talking about,
do you?
Yes, exactly, we're talking about Wuhan's
famous Coronavirus, the COVID-19 disease that
is spreading around the world and has not
yet reached its peak of infection.
At the time of producing this video, the virus
has reached 37 countries, more than 90,000
people have been infected and of them, more
than 3,200 have succumbed to the disease.
As you’re probably aware, this new strain
of Coronavirus, the seventh one to be identified,
is believed to have originated in a food market
in the Chinese city of Wuhan, where live animals,
including wild animals, were sold.
As you can imagine, such an epidemic can have
a great impact... on all levels.
And, look, I'm not just talking about health,
but also about the knock-on effects in politics
and, of course, the consequences for the economy.
(AUDIO: China’s Coronavirus Has Revived
Global Economic Fears - The New York Times)
(AUDIO: Alibaba Warns Virus Having Broad Impact
on Chinese Economy - Bloomberg)
(AUDIO: Factories Facing "Severe" Labor Shortages
In China, U.S. Business Group Says - Forbes
“Stocks tumble as haven assets rally on
coronavirus fears
Investors shift away from riskier assets on
signs outbreak is gathering pace outside China
Investors have rushed out of equities and
into havens such as gold and US government
bonds following a surge in coronavirus cases
in Italy, South Korea and Iran over the weekend
that intensified concerns over the global
impact of the virus.”)
Of course, the epicentre, the full brunt of
this terrible story is being felt in China,
especially in Hubei Province, which is where
Wuhan is located, the city where the outbreak
allegedly started.
China has suffered intensely from the threat
of the Coronavirus: city streets are now virtually
empty, many factories, malls and shops of
all kinds have closed their doors.
People are afraid to use public transport.
And some places like Hubei Province are still
paralyzed.
Locked down in quarantine.
People can't leave their houses and even car
journeys have been banned.
Written permits are needed for everything,
and you can no longer go to the pharmacy or
do your grocery shopping, now everything has
to be ordered online.
Dear friends, in an upcoming video here on
VisualPolitik, we will discuss in detail what
the long-term economic consequences of such
a threat might be.
So you know, if you haven't already done so,
don't miss out, subscribe to find out what’s
going on.
However, this time we're going to take a 90-degree
turn.
In this video, we're talking about Cathay
Pacific, Hong Kong’s flagship airline that's
having a really hard time right now.
Wait a minute, why on earth are we going to
talk about an airline?
Well, because this company, Cathay Pacific,
is, a good example of how everything related
to economics can suffer with the outbreak
of the Coronavirus and also how not even this
major healt threat has been enough to stop
the expansionism of the Chinese government.
But...
Let's start at the beginning.
While companies around the world have begun
to suffer due to a scarcity in components
from Chinese suppliers due to factory closures
and a lack of workers, Cathay Pacific is missing
passengers.
Okay, in Hong Kong cases still hover around
100, but fear is in the air.
And friends, this epidemic couldn’t have
come at a worse time for this airline.
Anti-government protests that have been burning
in the streets of Hong Kong for months, and
of which we have already discussed here on
VisualPolitik, have caused arrivals of visitors
and tourists to the city to fall faster than
the value of the Argentinian Peso.
(CHART)
In 2019, 9 million fewer visitors arrived
in Hong Kong compared with the previous year.
And now with the coronavirus...
All signs indicate that 2020 could be even
worse.
In fact, check this out.
During January 2020, visitors to Hong Kong
dropped 53% compared to the same month in
the previous year.
And in January 2020, the spectre of this coronavirus
was relatively smaller.
That makes the forecasts for the coming months
pretty bleak.
So, what kind of companies do you think suffer
the most in circumstances like this?
Well...
Yes, obviously hotels and airlines.
Those kinds of businesses feel the pinch as
people stay home.
Friends, the political crisis in Hong Kong
was a major blow to Cathay Pacific.
Now the impact of the Coronavirus may be the
last straw.
Now, exactly how great is the fallout?
How is the appearance of the Coronavirus affecting
this airline?
What steps are they taking?
What is the future of a company that has already
been suffering an unprecedented crisis for
almost a year?
Over the past few years, Cathay Pacific's
story has been filled with misfortune, political
blackmail, threats and political layoffs.
Listen to this.
(CATHAY’S ‘ANNUS HORRIBILIS’)
Friends, before we start talking about Cathay
Pacific's problems, I think it's best to get
a deeper understanding of the company.
Cathay Pacific is a flagship company, Hong
Kong's most important company.
And we're not exactly talking about a small
airline, but one of the largest air groups
across the Asian continent.
For you to get an idea, the size of its fleet
today is 152 aircraft, all of them wide-body
craft.
And not only that, besides the main airline
brand, this company also operates another
passenger subsidiary, Cathay Dragon, with
a fleet of 48 more aircraft, and a cargo subsidiary,
Air Hong Kong, with 11 aircraft.
That is, we are talking about an air group
with more than 200 operational aircraft and
routes to 130 destinations across the globe.
However, 2019 turned out to be a horrible
year.
And as we have mentioned, 2020 could be even
worse.
During the first month of 2020, passenger
arrivals at Hong Kong airport decreased by
40% year-on-year.
This has meant that both the number of passengers
and the volume of cargo carried by this airline
has been in freefall in recent months.
You see, in aviation, occupancy data is usually
measured by the passenger load coefficient,
which calculates the relationship between
seats per kilometre offered by an airline
and seats that were occupied.
(CHART)
As you can see, the second half of 2019 was
horrible for Cathay compared to 2018.
And it’s a similar story with the cargo
subsidiary.
In other words, this is a clear illustration
of the economic damage that has resulted from
the difficult political situation that Hong
Kong is going through at present.
It also explains news stories like this one:
(AUDIO: Hong Kong Suffers First Annual Recession
in a Decade.
Hong Kong’s economy contracted by 1.2% in
2019.
Global trade turbulence and months of anti
government protests pushed the city into its
first annual recession since the depths of
the global financial crisis in 2009.
WSJ)
And now there’s also the coronavirus to
contend with.
(AUDIO: Cathay Pacific issues profit warning
after coronavirus hits service - The Guardian)
Perhaps all of this explains why Cathay's
shares have reached their lowest price in
more than 10 years.
However,, this is not the only threat facing
the airline, nor the population of Hong Kong.
Because the truth is that we may be witnessing
what is perhaps the last move in a game that
could put an end to Hong Kong as we know it.
Check this out:
(IS THE FUTURE IN CHINA’S HANDS?)
Friends, when a company is struggling, apart
from the shareholders, the first ones to notice
the consequences are usually employees.
Following the coronavirus epidemic, Cathay
has been forced to suspend 90% of its flights
to mainland China and 30% of all its flights
globally.
With such severe cuts to their services, the
company has asked 27,000 employees to take
three weeks of unpaid leave to reduce fixed
costs and try to cope with the difficult situation
it is faced with.
However, this is not the only problem facing
this airline.
Remember how we were talking about the protests
in Hong Kong?
Well, friends, the drop in visitor numbers
was by no means the only negative impact from
that event that Cathay Pacific faced.
Are you familiar with the consequences of
angering the Chinese regime?
Well, let's just say that Cathay completed
an accelerated master's degree in the matter.
You see, after the protests broke out, several
workers who participated in them were unlucky
enough to be identified by the Chinese authorities.
And do you know what Beijing did?
Well, they said: Good job controlling your
employees; they keep participating in the
protests.
Soon you're going to realise the error of
your ways – soon you won't have a single
permit to fly in China.
You know, trademark authoritarian moves.
The pressure from the Chinese government that
said that the airline had not done enough
to control the political activities of its
workers ended up in the resignation of former
CEO Rupert Hogg and the President of Cathy
himself, John Slosar.
Following these two resignations, the airline
launched a heavy-handed policy against all
those employees who participated in the protests
and even those who had showed support for
the cause through social media campaigns.
At least two dozen workers were instantly
dismissed.
Yes, China forcing a company to curb the political
participation of its employees.
It’s crazy, but that's just how Xi Jinping's
government rolls.
But this shady story doesn't end there.
Here on VisualPolitik we have already told
you how the Republic of China is trying, by
all means possible, to consolidate its power
in Hong Kong.
Well... now it seems the Chinese government
has found a new way to attack.
Let me explain.
Cathay Pacific's current financial problems
stemming from the Hong Kong protests and exacerbated
by the coronavirus might just be the golden
opportunity for China, once and for all, to
take control of Hong Kong’s main transportation
provider.
And it’s nothing if not determined.
For more than a decade, China's quintessential
state airline, Air China, has owned 30% of
Cathay Pacific's shares.
It is the second largest shareholder behind
Hong Kong group Swire Pacific, which controls
45% of the shares.
So the truth is that if the Hong Kong airline's
bad run continues, China could be in an optimal
position to inject capital and take control
of the company.
In this way, its control over the lives of
Hong Kongers and the future of this city would
be even greater.
Yes, this shows us that Xi Jinping's government
knows how to take advantage of all situations,
even one as terrible as that fostered by Coronavirus.
In any case, when it comes to Hong Kong, it
seems that in Beijing they have a clear idea:
the worse it gets down there, the better it
will be for China.
Friends, Cathay Pacific is nothing more than
a microcosm of everything that is happening
in Hong Kong, a socially burning city that
every day seems closer to being devoured by
the Chinese giant.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.